everybody what's going on welcome to the
live Q&A for our conan japan episode we
are aware a week right now guys we're
not in California we're in Chicago right
on the Conan and Friends Comedy Tour
just play the Chicago theater last night
yeah a very successful show sold-out
crowd
sold-out crowd we are now in Hotel
Brussels yeah we didn't sell out we sold
out the show and then I sold out a long
time ago just so funny it's good and we
are here in a hotel room it's very cold
outside but Japan show yeah aired last
night very excited about that that's
right I'm proud of that one I think
there's some good moments in that show
absolutely we are on Instagram and
Facebook and we're taking your questions
so get him in while the gettin's good
and let's talk first of all about one
thing we did it we've done it several
other shows we did in this one was an
etiquette lesson so which I think didn't
go the way you thought it was gonna go
the women were a little more well okay
let's cut to the chase
yes it's cuz I had always been told that
Japanese in Japanese culture etiquette
is very important and behaving properly
and respecting their space and I wanted
to do that while I was in Japan I think
I'm culturally sensitive so mike sweeney
found a place called
breakfast jump was it cool Chuck these
luck Japanese lunch Japanese lunch and
we went there and what you're seeing in
that segment is real
this woman instantly started to make it
clear she didn't find me attractive then
got various percentage 26 within 20
seconds that she didn't think I was
attractive she was on the clock yeah and
I spend when she do like my face she
didn't like my body then she said she
did like my legs and she said if I just
focus on the legs she's okay with me but
she wants to block out the rest I just
tore
to shreds it'll exhibition very into
yeah and I think I've been a little
manorexic since that since we shot that
you taught in your head really took it I
took I took it hard I've noticed I have
not had a car since I met that woman and
I blame her
they're good that's offense yeah they
should be trainer yeah fast guys go to
Joe go to Japanese lunch and ask this
woman do you think I'm attractive you
will be eating ice cubes for the rest
anyway
Rick on Facebook asked what do the
people of Japan think of your hair I
think they're they sort of look at it as
if you know every now and then they pull
a creature from the bottom of the sea
because it's an adept a living fossil a
living fossil or like a sea anenome
that's got nine eyes that those are the
looks I was getting sort of wonderment
most of Wonderman you did yeah we did
stick out quite a bit
awesome he's asking where's the coach of
a video that's gonna be released later
but we did visit Kojima studios it was
very cool a lot of top-secret stuff
there and we had to be we have to be a
little delicate with the timing of that
yes because they were incredibly nice to
us yes and he's an incredibly cool guy
obviously brilliant yeah and he did ask
could we release that closer to when
possibly yes they're getting ready to do
their thing and we wanted to respect
that so we're not we can disclose their
creating the entire game on laptop yeah
it's just it's a check-in room with just
one giant room
oddly a laptop from 1998 yeah that's
that's that's like that's how they like
to work got a lot of stickers on it this
is kind of a larger question but I don't
know where we go when we die
maybe this room maybe were already that
this might be yeah this is our purgatory
right but life with people ask how is
visiting each country for Kohn Without
Borders changed your perception of their
culture
you know we Mike you do a lot of
research before we go and then when
we're there you're just kind of thrown
into the mix it has have we been to a
country that has been significantly
different than you thought before we
went Wow well obviously every country is
you can't imagine it until you're there
so we can do all the reading and prep we
want but not until you get there and you
merce yourself with the people you're
never gonna have an accurate that's true
repression just from you have to go
there I mean I would say the biggest
Seoul Korea was such an amazing
experience love the people but also just
the city and and and how massive it is
Tokyo that's 30 million it's crazy
Tokyo yeah you cannot you can watch lost
in translation a hundred times and still
not get Tokyo I wasn't ready for how
macula it was literally yeah I show up
in a guy's book that's the thing about
Tokyo that doesn't that doesn't show up
in a guidebook that you we were driving
through Tokyo and we went under a sort
of an iron overpass ya know the kind of
things that you see in Queens
you know we're Chicago right Chicago
Manhattan look at the underside of those
brothers in the United States and
they're just know being rusty and
there's stuff up there that's been up
there for 50 years
Levante cocoons yeah exactly we
a thunder one in Tokyo and I looked up
because we had a glass roof on the car a
sunroof and I looked up and clearly
they've been cleaning the underside of
an overpass and say that three times
fast I couldn't believe it and when you
walk around people are just polishing
the drop like delivery trucks that would
normally be disgusting the United States
or Japan
trash cans are beautiful there I said we
were in a neighborhood I just like
that's where the where's all the guard
thank you got mine from any hardware Wow
and it says you know there's no garbage
anywhere in LA he says that's because I
think he's friend of Max's look he's
bragging about LA there's no garbage in
LA what do you know it says that's
because they try to turn it all into a
television show happy baby on Facebook
has asked what that what's today
hoppy baby oh my god that's good Horace
is actually requesting Conan do more
episodes featuring your new family your
new father is probably my favorite
character since Carl all the Olsen and
the guy with the bulletproof legs ah my
new dad and this is look I want to get
make it clear my dad I talked to him
yesterday my real dad and I do love my
dad but this guy is in an improved
version I just have a great relationship
with him he told me I was his favorite
son yes but he forgave me
he asked for my forgiveness for spilling
the creamed corn on the linoleum floor
for getting mad about it I don't know I
loved that family I really did love that
family and my current family should be
threatened haha because I'm very tempted
to switch
they laugh at my jokes it was incredible
and you guys play frisbee you went on a
picnic I mean it was I think you really
bonded
well you that was such a brilliant idea
and Mike you can tell us but I think you
get that idea you got that idea from a
New Yorker didn't you we got it from a
New Yorker article about we get most
spread news from New Yorker The Paris
Review and so that it was article about
these rented families so it just
explored and they said yeah we can spell
together that wouldn't fell together
very very is very in and I loved the guy
who ran the company he was spent at you
know that the man I met with yeah and he
was I think he was I love it no matter
what I said I wouldn't add up my way to
say ridiculous things to him and he was
all being translated for him and he was
listening going hmm
yes yes I'm like saying the most
ridiculous things and he's nodding his
head and then I asked how long can I
keep them for and he said four years I
think three years I do want to do shout
out to Jason Shlomi yes
just ask what was a royal brilliant
Jason is one who we have these ideas and
he he found he's the one who fed
Japanese lunch oh yeah yeah Jason he
does it all with our local he OE spines
a fixer that's right locally and then we
he has this great relationship with them
yeah
and Jason just it's a nice story Jason
Swamy started really early on like what
94 95 as an intern yup and then he has
become these travel shows would not
if it were not for Jason chalets he
makes them all and he's great no matter
what goes wrong and occasionally it's
the rod that he's just super chill takes
care of everything it's fantastic yeah
it's okay yeah also uh Masada a John are
two fixers in Japan yes thank you
Masato John thank you very much Belen
Lopez on facebook says as asking what
was your favorite meal in Japan there's
a very specific fancy meal you had yes I
had a video I would say I'm not talking
about the food itself but for the
experience
kosecki having the Kentucky meal with
Jordan and having him go on and on about
obscene Karate Kid 2 and that being the
reason for 10 years of pomp of pompous
[ __ ] babble about Japanese culture
and then all was because it was really
filmed in where do you say it was like
okay now they said Okinawa and to have
him to have that video from Ralph
Macchio not Macchio loaded up and watch
Jordan milk perfectly walked right into
the crosshair and you can see me waiting
and I'm like I'm just I'm gonna cap it's
about to beat the canary and then I hand
it to him and then I don't think just
let him go and go and use wait and Kevin
the Chang I Facebook is asking everyone
Stewart and actually upset yeah yeah
yeah Jordan was mad Jordi I think they
go we had to edit out some of his stuff
it was too ugly you had to
yeah it was serious oh my god he got
really mad and we actually had a live
stream going yeah there are people out
there that watch the live stream yeah
[ __ ] said oh my god he's rich Orton got
really mad and I have to give right the
guy knows but Ralph Macchio I really do
he was he made that tape for us and he
was great and it came in and it was
perfect and obviously he's a very
talented guy and and but I'm very much
in his debt that was perfect so Ralph
Macchio and thank you what a cool guy
didn't do that and he did it perfectly
they don't for talked about this yes we
went to research everybody kid to
because we thought oh he loves this
movie yeah and I think there was a big
thing amongst the rest of us because we
wanted to get him on camera I wanted to
nail my camera so Jordan you know for
some reason yes its way of finding out
about that he just knows things and so
we were all I think really nervous about
whether or not he's not yeah yo he's
about you wanted Jordans reaction on
camera is real yes didn't know that was
coming though he was stunned then he was
angered by the computer how in 2001 he's
starting to fall apart and try to kill
everybody you want to bring up quick
special guest appearance yes I want to
step over here just for a second we'll
talk
if you want to come on learn despite
having the same no I know your what you
were on it you were good because I soda
interesting sidenote few fans out there
so no was a little bit happier Jonah was
in Japan at the same time we were but
you were I was on my honey honey baby
she was on her honeymoon but she's not
in the show because that would have been
creepy it would have been would have
been did you we never really got too
close to each other we were always in
different cities Tokyo I was in Kyoto
how where is it you would even plan that
we went to Tokyo and only later on did
we realize that your honeymoon was lined
up for the exact same time literally
almost day-to-day that we were gonna be
there right
I don't know just thought that was kind
of a cool coincident was nervous that
that maybe we had planned something to
try to ambush you guys no I think I
would have been if it was in Tokyo but
ya know we work in travel to Kyoto you
did some extremely cool which we didn't
get to see you to assume oh yes so you
want explain though I went to the sumo
competition which was one of the coolest
things I've ever done it was awesome but
it was it starts at 8:00 in the morning
and it goes on though about 6:00 in the
evening and what it's yeah it's it's I I
mean it I don't even know how many
competitions and they all come it's all
very ceremonial it's really cool and you
know you guys should go back to right as
a match well with the ceremony and
everything each one is about and then
actually themselves are quick they're
like 15 seconds but the ceremony
beforehand it makes them each like five
minutes no we got really into it
briana mercury on facebook a sweat so no
what was your favorite part of japan and
also what was your favorite part of the
japan show my favorite part of japan was
probably the efficiency in the renting
the family was possibly my favorite
thing i've done i just drops the mic
your family drops the mic and we're all
we've only got three more minutes so get
your questions in now and noren hua
wrote on Facebook asked where is George
what is he doing while we're on tour
what you know what we've had is by
watching this I like I take questions at
the end of every show yes which is it
I'm touring with these you know really
funny comedians I go out first and
and do comedy whatever for for about
half an hour so and then we have these
great comedians Taylor Tomlinson is with
us now James V Ron Funches
just brilliant comedians Flula Borg is
with us emceeing and he's hilarious and
we've had Rory Scovel and marina
Franklin and more comments to come this
is a really fun tour I'll say every
night when I take questions maybe the
second or third question is where's
Jordan and people are obsessed with
Jordan and is he real and is he real and
the answer is he is real he's a real
person that's really who he is
he really does irritate me but he also
fascinates me and it's very complicated
to explain but I like Jordan and I also
dislike him and I can't explain it
and but it sounds like Merritt
yes but yeah so he is real and right now
he is back home in Los Angeles I believe
right yes I think so
he was white planned a young child as he
is we're just at probably today just
feeling phone calls and emails about the
Ralph Macchio well I will kind of end
maybe on this question which is the
question we always end which is David
when a facebook asks what country would
you most like to visit next everybody's
always asking where is next word it's
there's no one we can't say right now
what is next
we know we want to go to India yeah just
have to go to India
oh there's there's a couple of countries
that we have up our sleeve that we want
to visit but I mean if you can and also
we take fan suggestions I mean it's
really some of our best adventures have
been you know fans inviting us the whole
common town
yes kind of topping happened and that
got us to Tokyo yeah so we also I mean
it's in your hands as much as probably
more than it's in our hands
yeah if you have an idea where we should
go or if you're watching this in your
country and you have a good organic
reason why we should come let us know
yeah
send us snacks mail yourself blue bars
now I think so yeah it's like it takes
what 280 days it's not these six months
yeah you do it okay he runs and then you
know just do the show it'd be a good
challenge to do a country that know
people I can't write it go oh yeah the
Iceland people say could be fun Iceland
will be interesting via phone well
that's gonna do it for our code in Japan
live Q&A again we're in Chicago from
Chicago yeah that's right they'll go
into Minneapolis tonight yeah Milwaukee
and then we're on to Milwaukee the next
day so if you want to come if you're
anywhere in that area or you want to or
you're in Peru but you want to fly it
into London right now and see us live
this out we'll also be obviously in LA
Vancouver Denver and San Francisco
coming up and follow hashtag Conan and
friends to see everything we're doing on
tour go to Team Coco calm slash Japan to
see all sorts of bunch of stuff from the
cone in Japan episode and thank you guys
for watching
we're gonna be doing another Facebook
lot very soon so make sure you tune in
from Chicago outside and signing off
we'll see you guys later